There's a question from the YouTube IA
creativity. Asalamu alaikum. My name is
Isba from Pakistan. Why don't you give
public lectures as you used to give
before? The question asked by Isba is
that why don't I give public lectures as
I used to give before? The answers can
be divided into two or three parts.
Number one, I remember when I started
doing dava in the early 90s, you know, I
got inspired by Shik Gid in 1987. I was
doing mainly onetoone dhava. Then in the
early '90s, I started giving public
talks and then I started traveling. The
first talk I think I gave was in South
Africa in 1994.
My first talk outside India and then I
remember I have to give a lot of talks.
I remember when I went to Kuwait in 1998
in one day I gave eight talks one is
immediately after fudger early in the
morning and last talk was 2:00 in the
night eight talks eight public talks in
a day I remember when I used to travel
towards the end of the ' 90s and the
early parts of 2000 I used to spend
maybe a few days and I have to give tens
of lectures on average few lectures a
day maybe more than one lecture a day
two three lectures a day on Okay. So I
spend there about 5 days and about maybe
10 15 lectures. We spend a week and we
give maybe 20 lectures. Later on with
the help of Allah subhanana wa tala as
as time went on growing alhamdulillah
Allah gave more power in my speech Allah
put love and mercy into the heart of the
people. Previously when I used to give
lectures my audience I remember Ahmed
the person who inspired me Allah grant
ja rahimah he had told me when you come
to Saudi Arabia expect few people don't
expect the way you get in India
thousands of people and the first talk I
gave in Saudi Arabia it was in 1996
if I'm not mistaken my first talk in cha
I was expecting maybe 10 15 people and
mashallah more than a thousand people
came so Allah has blessed that initially
when it started only the numbers were in
thousands. Okay. Western countries were
initially few hundred then into
thousands but as talks as Allah kept on
putting love of me into the hearts of
the Muslims and even many of the
non-Muslims then the strategy changed
and
maybe in the year 2010 onward etc I
preferred giving few lecture with larger
audiences and that's how my talks became
few but the numbers became much and then
then we were more involved in the media.
We used to record the programs and see
to it that many people used to watch. So
that's how most of the talks abroad you
know used to have large gathering maybe
in if you see from the year 2010 to 2016
we have to travel a lot the audiences
abroad with 5,000 10,000 20,000 50,000
you know large gatherings in India it
was 100,000 200,000 500,000 1 million so
few lectures larger audience if you
count the number of people in public
talks every year increased mean if I
gave I went to a city and spend five
days and give maybe 15 talks or spend
two weeks and give 20 talks. Now I go to
a country I give talks only on the
weekends but the number of people coming
for the talks for those two talks are
much more than 10 talks put together
that's number one but that's not the
only thing we also record this on the
media and when it goes on the social
media the social media people watch to a
larger number on social media and on the
satellite channel. So when we started
the satellite channel in 2006, our main
focus was see to it that programs on the
satellite channels are good. So my talks
became less but the reach became more.
Now the satellite in 2016 appear TV
English alone had 100 million viewers.
Then Udu mashallah had 80 million
viewers. Bangla had 50 million viewers.
Chinese had 20 million viewers. Now the
viewership has a little bit declined. So
previously it was about 250 million all
put together. Now it may have reduced to
maybe 200 million all put together you
know because more people are watching
social media but the television yet has
its advantage. So now because of social
media we're coming on the social media
the Facebook is there now my Facebook at
23.9 million martial subscribers the
YouTube has 3.89 8 n million subscribers
and Instagram so on so forth. So in
terms of lectures I do agree with the
public lectures I do agree it has
reduced and you know because of the
onslaught of the Indian government 2016
after that 2016
I only started traveling to countries
which are more friendly to Muslims as
well as those countries which I know
doesn't have good hold of India as you
know that because of the onslaught of
the Indian government the BJP P
government Narendra Modi had to do Hijra
in 2016 from India to Malaysia. After I
did Hijra, of course the Indian
government was after me. So after 2016,
whenever I traveled to any country
whether Muslim or non-Muslim country, I
did not travel to the country until I
had invitation from the head of state or
the home. So all the country that I've
traveled after 2016
all it was an invitation or it was a
sanction or a nod from the head of state
whether it be the prime minister or the
president or the shake or the king or
the person or from the home ministry
because I wanted to be safe and secure
because India is a very powerful country
and you know that Modi is very powerful
and is close to many countries
especially Muslim countries. So any
country I went I saw to it that it was
hosted by the government by the head of
state or by the home minister. So that's
the reason after 2016 one of the reasons
that the countries where I to travel
before without this condition I stopped
going the invitations are yet coming
anyone invites me I say if you give me
the invitation from the head of state or
from the home ministry I'll come I
remember in 2020 April I was invited a
couple of months I think in January 2020
I was invited there's going to be a
program in April in Canada where Justin
Trudeau
who is the
president of uh the prime minister of uh
Canada he was going to be the chief
guest. I was called as a guest of honor
and there was a Muslim MP was invited
and accepted that because it was through
the government and indirectly the head
of state of Canada was there but
unfortunately because of COVID
because of COVID the program was canled.
So one thing that in between okay in
2016 I traveled to many countries 17 I
traveled but during the span when I came
and I migrated to Malaysia I was here
for one or two one year rest and then I
started traveling again but then cover
came so in 2020
and 21
I did not travel because of co but one
thing good that happened is I started
the session as Dr. Zak in 2020 I
remember in Ramadan it was in April the
lockdown came in March and I said okay
now I cannot travel all the programs
have been cancelled there were no talks
not in Malaysia not outside what to do
and I'm I like giving talks so we
started this ask Dr. Zakir and that time
when we started in Ramsan in April 2020
I used to give twice a week but then I
realized that giving twice a week
reading the questions you know we
thought it will be easy only the talk
and maybe you know couple of hours of
preparation and giving the talk you know
we realize that average in a week 20,000
questions started coming so the biggest
ordeal is to read these questions so I
had a team and my team doesn't read all
the 20,000 maybe 5,000 6,000 whatever
they read from that they pass me 100
questions from that 100 I select 20
questions to answer approximately. So
then after Ramadan it's you know because
of all my other activities there
satellite etc. I reduced it to once a
week and when the co ended maybe in 2021
2022 when my son Farik came to Malaysia
or he was in Saudi that time we used to
join I used to handle one and a half
hour my son half and half but when he
came to Malaysia then I handle ask Dr.
Zakir on the first and the third
Saturday and my son handles as Shikhik
Farik on the second and the fourth
Saturday. So many but because we reduced
I changed from 1 and a half hour to 2
hours so the length has remained
approximately same previously was in
Ramadan it was 1 hour twice a week then
became one and a half hour once a week
now it becomes 2 hours to 2 hours 15
it's twice a month so it comes to
approximately 1 hour a week for me and
far edition takes 1 hour every fortnight
so 2 hours a month but natural the
audience on the social media live on the
Facebook on the YouTube on the Instagram
on the peace TV the thing is large but
coming back to your question yes public
talks has reduced now one thing is there
I prefer public talks because in public
talks I enjoy and I'm giving a talk
standing I can see the audience live
it's different than talking in front of
a camera both are different but one good
thing that happened in ask Dr. Zakin
sessions. We are in the 12th season. The
first Ramadan season had about nine uh
sessions. Now each of the season have
normally six sessions sometimes seven.
So already 12. So already more than 70
sessions have taken place you know of
one and a half to two hours and more
than thousand one one and a half
thousand questions have been answered.
The difference in this and the public
lecture is the public lectures is good
of course inspiring you know lot of
cameras audiences there 5,000 10,000
20,000 50,000 and even in this time in
Malaysia before the cover I had I had
given the talk just before the co 2019
when I gave a talk in in Malaysia in
Clantan there were more than 100,000
people in 2017 when I gave in Indonesia
there were 110,000 people in Jakarta. So
the audiences of course those talks with
the number of cameras 12 it's much
better in terms of impact it is 10 to 20
times better but as far as the talks are
concerned excellent as far as the
questions are concerned there were many
questions which were repetitive and we
cannot say this question has been asked
one year back I cannot answer I cannot
say this question was yes if it's asked
same day I can refuse answering or if
asked yesterday in another talk in the
same city I can say it was answered
yesterday but I cannot say it was
answered one month back in Nigeria or
one month back in Qatar I have to answer
so there were questions which were
repetitive so if you remove the
duplicate suppose every public talk I
may handle about 10 to 20 questions out
of which more than 50% are repetition
or some questions which ask twice some
three times some 10 times so the net
impact You could say unique question you
could say 25% only absolutely unique in
this program ask Dr. Zakir the
repetitions are very few maybe less than
10%.
If I so when we get this 20,000 question
my staff has been trained that if there
questions normally which have already
answered in public lectures avoid them
if it is already answered in this avoid
them. Sometimes there are prediction if
it has a different angle. So there are
questions which are repeated. Therefore
I say 10% less than that. It may have a
different angle. So half the answer may
be same half may be new. So the
questions are are unique. So in these
three years 20 21 22 know this three
three or four years the question on my
ask Dr. Zakir is
more information than all my questions
in about 15 years of my public lecture.
Yes, I purposely do not repeat what I've
already given. So most of the
comparative questions I've answered in
the public. I'm not answering here. Most
of the common questions I'm not it's
being asked but I'm not selecting it. So
the difference in this is that which is
more beneficial for the um so I feel
that the this question answer session of
course the impact of the audience is so
better. I personally love it more. I
like the audience. I get the live feel.
But the benefit for the ummah is that
this question answer session has its own
impact. The talk has its own impact. But
the second part of the talk with the
question answer session this is better.
So I feel both are required. That's the
reason I have given my editors more
vitage for editing the question answer
session. They ask Dr. Zakir. So both has
of course the impact of a public lecture
with the audience with the Jimmy Jim.
This is only three cameras that is a 10
15 20 cameras and now coming to your
question again that there was a gap for
about 2 years and when it restarted I
remember the first talk I gave was in
2022 in Malaysia in ples it was the
first public lecture allowed in Malaysia
after the restrictions of covid and
there the authorities put restriction
not more than thousand people so
thousand people came it was Dr. Dr.
Zakir history Dr. is actually nice story
you know from Bombay to Hijra to
Malaysia and it was a 2 and a half hours
lecture now the situation is that when I
started sending the request I'll only
allow I will only accept invitation if
it's from head of state in this year
I got invitation from about 14 countries
normally normally for public lectures in
2016 2015 I normally accept invitations
you know pure public lectures about
three or four three or four countries
and in the Gulf country Gulf country was
common going to Dubai going to Saudi
going to katar was common so besides
these three countries where I have to go
repetitive every year additional maybe
three countries now in this year I
received invitation from 12 to 14
countries
fulfilling this criteria. So I decided
okay I will go to at least eight
countries this year. So because of that
mashallah we recently just a couple of
months back we purchased the best of
cameras
you know when we used to travel before
to any country abroad we used to travel
with a crew of about 50 to 55 people
crew with me and my family about 60
people used to travel. So when we went
to Gambia we went to Nigeria that time
you know so crew used to go along. So at
that time we should have 14 cameras.
This time we purchased again the best
cameras that's available in the world.
Just a couple of months back we
purchased the Sony V2 which is 8.6K and
we purchased the ona lens which is the
best lenses in the world. What we did
that we purchased the seven high quality
best cameras in the world and we are
continuing with these cameras that we're
recording. These are the FX9 which are
cinematic cameras but of a lower end. So
we'll do the recording with 10 cameras
and we decided to travel with about 15
20 people. Previously it was 15 to 60
people. Now we decided we will make the
crew a bit less. So 20 people and
because we accepted the invitation
that's the reason this ask Dr. Zakir did
not happen for the last 6 months. I was
away but naturally there was Hamzan in
it there was Hajj not only lectures but
even now I was supposed to travel to an
African country but because there were
some problem and riots that got
postponed and inshallah it will again
start from September September October
November December again I'll be
traveling and when I travel as Dr. Zak
night doesn't take place because they're
busy with there. So both has it pros and
cons. Allah knows best. He had the ask
Dr. Zak night you know for about 3 years
and then it reduced it yet continuing
now inshallah from this year onwards
from 2024 there'll be more public
lectures and inshallah I hope it'll
benefit for the um it will benefit me in
this world and also in the Akra. So the
public lectures inshallah will not be
the same as before in the 90s and 2000s
but inshallah go back to what we used to
do in 2013 14 15 16 where travel at
least to four five countries and have
large audience and we pray to Allah
subhanaa tala that now the audiences
will be larger there are new topics that
have come so the matter in terms of
available to the public on the social
media on the video on the satellite has
increased multiple times more in terms
of duration. It may be similar but in
terms of uniqueness it is more and I
also spend time in doing more research
that is these questions are asked the
selection takes a lot of time reading
takes a lot of time and then selecting
is main thing and then we are more
selecting those questions which are
suppose asked by atheist against Islam
asked by those people who while posing
to Muslims they can get deviated. So it
has its own benefit. That's the reason I
enjoy the session of Dr. Zakir. But I
also miss the the programs. Now what I
miss one thing wasn't asked by you which
I'm missing more. It is the peace
conferences.
The peace conference is something what I
miss the most since I've left India
especially Bombay. The thing that I
missed the most
besides
my family
that's my parents and brothers and
sisters the thing that I really missed
in terms of dawa is the peace conference
other things alhamdulillah but the peace
conference the way we used to have in
Bombay you know we had for many years
and the audiences used to be hundreds of
thousands in one sitting over 10 years
about a million people you know the
audience is coming in large numbers 30
more than 30 speakers coming from
different parts of the world This this
we missed and I was hoping to have this
and I spoke to a few people about which
is the best place to have it. You know
which country would be the best and
unfortunately unfortunately
most of the Muslim countries may not
like having such large audiences and
large number of speakers coming. But
there's good news for you. Inshallah,
inshallah
after 6 months
in January
that is in the last week of January from
the 24th,
25th, 26th for 3 days, Friday, Saturday,
Sunday 2025, we'll be having not the
same level of the peace conference what
we used to have in in Bombay, but we'll
be having the pearly sunnah convention.
This year there were six speakers and I
spoke to the mufti and the authorities
and they agreed this time they'll have
18 speakers going to be for 3 days and
18 speakers international speakers most
of them who come on peace will be there
it'll be for 3 days it will not be the
same
large audience but at least the speakers
will be together what we had done in
2022 because we could not we didn't have
a peace conference We had a
brainstorming session in Qatar in 2022
immediately after Ramadan in April and
May for about 5 days and we had the top
duats 14 coming and discussing about the
various aspects. In this time we'll be
having the pearl sunnah convention after
6 months in January 2025 and inshallah
it may not have that large audience but
we expect at least 10 at least 10,000
people to attend this convention. So the
peace conferences that are there where
large number of audiences that used to
have you know unlike any other
conferences will be the largest in the
world. Inshallah inshallah Allah will
make it possible that we'll have these
large conventions and conferences very
soon. Inshallah in the coming years
we'll have bigger conferences with large
number of duats see to it that the entry
is free absolutely free. So more number
of people can benefit from it. And I
pray to Allah subhanaa tala may he make
us instrumental in sparing the de.